à quelques pas de l'un des sites les
plus importants de la religion
catholique
une comédie musicale à broadway au pied
des pyrénées
[Musique]
l'enfance de bernadette soubirous mise
en scène une fille pauvre qui aurait vu
une dame bien particulière dans une
grotte il y à plus de 160 ans
sur scène les paroles de la vraie
bernadette interrogé par des adultes
incrédule et parfois agressés la sainte
vierge m'est apparu baptisation de
vierge ce sont des paroles en monsieur
vous m'avez tout change ici tu vas dire
sinon c'est cette détermination que le
metteur en scène québécois serge
denoncourt a voulu mettre en vedette
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut le voir comme le
petit musicale à saveur historique je
raconte vraiment une page d'histoire de
la france avec une héroïne française qui
est je me plais beaucoup à dire ça c'est
jeanne d'arc sans armée
[Musique]
une oeuvre produits interprété par des
français une quinzaine de québécois
forment le coeur de l'équipe de création
[Musique]
parmi eux le directeur artistique de
céline dion n'a pas voulu non plus
inspirés de l'univers religieux
le défi de faire quelque chose de bon 2
c'est au geste règles satisfaisant de
partir de quelque chose à son début et
de le voir arriver sur scène et suivront
le monde attendait ça c'est ça donne un
bon feeling
[Musique]
interprète principal chante depuis son
enfance elle parle aussi d'une histoire
qui peut inspirer tous les publics
parce que ces deux marques
c'est un message pour vraiment tout le
monde tout le monde peut se reconnaître
dans le rôle du père par exemple tout le
monde peut se reconnaître en bernadette
parce que c'est une fille assez moderne
je me nomme bernadette soumillon subir
aussi les représentations de bernadette
de lourdes son sous-titré en plusieurs
langues afin de rejoindre les millions
de pèlerins qui visitent le sanctuaire
chaque année
[Musique]
il est aussi question de présenter
l'oeuvre dans d'autres pays pratiquent à
quoi l'italie au brésil
là où l'exemple de bernadette est assuré
de trouver son public
ici avec du mont-bart en radio canada
lourd
[Musique]